welcome to the reason stream I'm Liz
wolf joined by my co-host Zack Weiss
Muer we're live today so please be a to
throw any questions that you might have
in the chat we're looking forward to
getting to some of your uh questions uh
hopefully providing some some pretty
good answers today we're talking about
Javier Malay the self-described
libertarian Economist running for
president of Argentina he surprised the
world with a first place finish in the
primaries this summer but in a runoff
this past Sunday he came in second to
Sergio Masa the minister of economy for
Argentina's ruling party Malay and Masa
will face voters once again on November
19 so does Malay still have a chance
joining us to offer insights into
Argentine politics is Marcos Falcone a
political scientist project manager at
Argentina's fund libertad um and podcast
host Marcus thank you for so much for
joining
us hi Liz Zach thank you for the invite
hey yeah let's look at uh what happened
in this most recent election uh what
exactly do you think explains this
outcome
Marcos yeah so um this was a surprise to
us uh just as the August primaries had
been a surprise um in Argentina we have
this system where um primaries are held
um at the same time for all parties and
voting is compulsory so this is why we
can compare the primaries to the general
election uh that took place uh this past
Sunday um in August we had seen mle um
win uh with 30% of the vote um he was ah
head of uh the other two coalitions um
that actually had primaries milay faced
no one uh within his Coalition um but
this time um although everyone expected
that there would be a second ballot um
which is going to take place November
19th um most people expected mle to win
again um and get more votes than Serio
Masa the current minister of economy or
Patricia bolid uh former minister of
security he ended up getting fewer votes
than Masa Masa got 30% vote uh mle got
30 which is the same basically as the
primaries um and this came as a shock it
seems to me that there are two main
reasons why this was the case um first
um M's campaign has not been the most uh
professional one uh he has talked about
uh issues that um are sort of out of
touch with the Argentine public uh that
may be of uh true interest uh to us
Libertarians uh such as you know whether
organs could be sold or bought uh but
that people is not really interested in
at the of course they should be what is
that
controversial right uh but but the thing
is you know uh his opponents um actually
attacked him uh for things like that um
and and that that probably uh took a
dent on his candidacy um and then just
you know overall there was this fear
campaign that if mle won um he would be
the sort of fascist you know who would
be a danger for democracy just like um
people in the US um talked about Donald
Trump in recent years or people Brazil
talked about Shah boson um M was
described as this very dangerous person
who should be who should not be
president so this is the reason why I
think uh it was Masa particularly who
got uh more votes um because mle was
sort of um competing with the rest of
the opposition for the anti-government
vote uh he won that if you if you take
that as a primary as another primary say
then he won that because he beat
Patricia B who will not be in the second
ballot uh but the government sort of
Consolidated its support um and got more
votes I think because of this fear
campaign and because it tried to focus
he try to avoid um economics basically
because um the presidential candidate is
the Minister of economy but our economy
is in shambles right now uh we have a
140% annual inflation rate um non-going
recession uh poverty rates that are
through the roof um so it was smart of
the government to try to avoid U the
economic themes and just focus on how
dangerous mle would be and I think
that's the reason why they got more
votes but it wasn't just the sphere
campaign right like Masa also engaged in
a little bit of uh I would say not
exactly trickery but almost like bribing
people to vote for him when it really
got down to the wire could I was even
reading a little bit about about how you
know people would show up to bus
stations and train stations and see the
government basically communicating oh if
Malay you know comes into Power then
here is how much your ticket will
actually be because it'll no longer be
subsidized by the government and he'll
slash all of these programs which is a
fairly compelling pitch to people who
are struggling financially could you
tell us a little bit about like what was
this very slimy campaign that Masa was
running yeah I mean it was all very
sketchy uh and it wasn't just that um
for people who don't who haven't been to
Argentina uh bus tickets uh train
tickets Subway tickets are highly
subsidized uh particularly in Buenos
heidas and so a bus ride can cost
something like um seven cents of a
dollar uh when the true price should be
something like a dollar and so who's
paying for that of course taxpayers uh
it's only indirectly that they're paying
for that with with for example this
monstrous inflation rate that we have U
but it's not something that you pay
directly and so what the government did
was they they actually installed um um
like signs that said you know if uh
without a subsidy you would be paying 10
times what you're paying today um which
was a very uh not a direct but a very
clear reference to um the fiscal
adjustment that both mle and buid uh
were proposing something else that um
Minister Masa did was he actually uh cut
taxes uh in these past two months uh
which is something that a uh leftist um
peronist government as we call it here
would never do um but this time they
they they do it um Minister Massa sort
of slashed uh income tax uh for actually
this was mostly for people who are high
earners in Argentina but he basically
slashed it um and he also um implemented
well he they passed a law that Minister
Masa sent to Congress which would um and
which is effective now and sort of gives
um money back to taxpayers the V attacks
it gives it back basically to Consumers
who use their debit card in supermarkets
uh in grocery stores um so there there
were lots of measures put in place by
the government government which are
already fueling inflation because uh the
September rate for example was uh
12.7% which was the highest uh monthly
rate in 30 years in Argentina um wow
really yeah I know right okay yeah um
and before that in August we we had you
know surpassed our record uh again so
this is like a continuous thing you know
every month we get higher inflation than
the previous one and it it is in part
because of these measures um they
weren't enough to sort of um call
markets down uh there still was a run
against the peso right before the
election um for people to to to get a
sense of of what the exchange rate is
here uh right after um um the August
primaries the dollar was trading at
something like 600 pesos um but right
before the election uh this past Sunday
the dollar was staining at something
like a thousand pesos so there was it
there was definitely a run against the
peso uh which minister Massa was unable
to contain um but still you know these
measures that he took these these very
populist measures uh they are very we're
used to them uh that that's probably why
I didn't even mention them in the first
place you know because we see that
happen uh repeatedly uh and regard
regardless of who the president is of
what their political affiliation is they
all try to take uh Implement measures
that will G get them uh the most votes
right before the election in the case of
Masa was tax cuts which alongside this
fear campaign I think were very
effective so you could say Malay has
already delivered his first tax cut just
through the fear of his election uh by
his political opponents but what you you
know when when Malay that's actually I'm
sorry that that's actually what he said
because he he has two seat in Congress
right now yeah he has two seats in
Congress one of them is actually him he
actually voted in favor of the tax cuts
and he told people you know this was
actually uh his doing all around that he
was forcing Masa to cut taxes through
his agenda so he he did that yeah yeah
uh and you know the the the giving out
of all the other good
obviously a terrible policy amidst an
inflation crisis right after melay CA
kind of surprisingly came in first this
summer in the initial in the initial
primary there was a market sort of
there's some panic in the market and you
wrote about this for National Review at
the time and said that that that morning
uh markets opened in panic mode local
ADR Clines of up to 14% before making a
partial comeback on the same day the
government devalued the national
currency by
22% in just two days the official
unofficial exchange rate Rose from 600
to 780 pesos per dollar does unofficial
exchange rate mean black market exchange
rate correct correct yeah so we have
multiple exchange rats but but I I can
go on I can go over that I just wanted
to clarify Zach can get to his question
I just wanted to clarify because
unofficial exchange rate might be
confusing for people who don't know
that's a good clarification what why did
that happen right after the kind of
surprise Victory or not Victory but
first place finish by
mle yeah so that that's kind of
paradoxical right because you would
expect a pro market candidate to get the
confidence of the market um but the
thing is um M's campaign um was not
really being Tak seriously by markets by
the public in general just because he
was not polling um above 20%
15% um in most uh polls and so everyone
expected him to be a very important like
a key figure um particularly in terms of
uh Congressional support for the next
president but nobody expected him to
become the next president and I don't
think he was even expecting uh the
August result when he came in uh first
so I think um because of all of this um
his proposals were not priced in uh sort
of the the local currency or bonds or
stocks and his main proposal uh back
then and still now was that of
dollarization um
dollarization means basically getting
rid of the peso which is our national
currency um and just declaring that you
know the dollar will be the the legal
tender in Argentina this has been done
in other Latin American countries um
like Ecuador Panama uh but it has not
been done in as big a country as
Argentina so this would be a very
interesting experiment but one of the
criticisms the main criticism of that
plan uh is that the Central Bank in
Argentina has negative reserves right
now so it has no
basically um it's indepted and so the
the key um issue that you need to solve
before doll dollar rizing is that of the
exchange rate you know if suddenly
you're going to get rid of the peso and
everyone's going to start using dollars
then what's the exchange rate the final
exchange rate going to be and because
the central bank has no dollars um
criticism of M was that the exchange
rate would have to be extremely high um
to account for these very few dollars
that the state has but if that happens
you know then that is very likely to
trigger hyperinflation particularly in
an economy that is already that already
has chronic chronically High inflation
um and so the fear in my opinion right
after the August primaries was that mle
was actually going to win the general
election or the second ballot that he
would do
but that the central bank would still
have no dollars which would trigger
chaos basically in the economy and we
know that markets uh like Market
friendly policies but they hate
uncertainty and they hate um you know
not knowing what's going to happen or
how that's GNA happen and it back then
you know in August it wasn't really
clear um how exactly Argentina was going
to dollarize uh if if he were to become
president because his economic team was
split uh there were at least two
uh opposing plans to dollarit and so it
it was all very complex nobody knew what
a what a melee Administration would
actually look like in terms of economics
so that sort of triggered that Panic uh
back then yeah and I I want to talk with
you a little bit more later in depth
about dollarization and some of his
policies and how those could be
implemented without complete the kind of
complete disaster that people were
fearing and sparked that panic but first
can we let's return to the election
results for just a moment um as you
mentioned the uh front runner uh or the
top finisher here Masa got about 30
almost 37% of the vote melay
29.9% of the vote almost 30% um and then
uh bullick with almost 24% so actually a
fairly even split between the three
could you just explain to us the
difference between these three main
these three top finishing parties and
candidates Yeah so basically um in Sasa
you find uh the the representative of
the current Administration he is the the
minister of economy um he is sort of
like um the the shadow president if you
will because the our president has
largely gone out of stage he he's doing
nothing really nobody really cares about
what the president is doing since like
the beginning of this year when he
announced that he was not going to go
for re-election he's deeply unpopular uh
but Masa represents uh the peronist
party uh that of Juan Domingo Peron um
who back in the 40s and the 50s um
introduced populist policies uh which
it's hard to explain because the parist
party um has many faces um some of them
tend to be leftist some of them tend to
be rightest and Masa is a perfect
example of that Masa actually started
his um political career in a center
right party uh in a sort of libertarian
party really back in the late 80s uh and
there are some people who still remember
him you know as defending economic
Liberty uh like strongly very strongly
but after joining the parist party he
sort of defended whoever uh the parist
in charge was which made him uh actually
oppose you know uh Nester and Christina
kersner who were presidents uh from 2003
to
2015 um he was a minister for that
government he then resigned he ran uh as
a presidential candidate against uh
kirner's uh candidate um so he's been
going back and forth you know between
leftist and rtist positions right now
he's the representative of the left in
Argentina of the center left um but this
volatility though so I feel like in
order to even attempt to begin to
understand Argentine politics you need
to understand what exactly the peronists
are and the fact that there's kind of a
few different like groups of them a few
different buckets that they can be
sorted into and then you also frankly
kind of need to understand the Legacy of
the C nurse so is there a way you can
try to put these in terms that American
audiences will understand we don't have
to get into the weeds of like fully
understanding the differences between
every sect of peronist but what exactly
you know are these political
groups right so the the pist party I
think it can be basically described as
the Workers Party of Argentina right uh
pedon attempted to represent uh workers
back in the 40s back in the 50s
um the policy measures that he
introduced back then were highly
populist you know um High public
spending uh running fiscal deficits uh
this is where the the problem The
Chronic problem of inflation started in
Argentina and all of this was done with
the intent of um improving the quality
of life of the poorest uh but then of
course you know it had the the reverse
effect of causing these inflation prices
Dev valuation of the currency which
impoverishes the poor the most um and so
Pon himself you know he was a populist
at times and then he sort of
um went back and said okay this is a
time where we need to stop we need to
stop with fiscal deficits we need to
stop with public spending because
otherwise this is all going to hell and
so people would just follow him you know
wherever he went when whenever he became
more populist or less populist then
after he died um he was also exiled
right he was exiled yeah he was I mean
he himself was part of a coup um who
gained power in the early 40s but he was
Ed by the by the military too uh in the
mid 50s um he then went back in the in
the early 70s he died in
1974 after that there was no clear um
successor uh in the parist party um and
Nestor kishner um moving forward you
know to the 2000s um he sort of claimed
to be pedone's successor you know a
representative of the of the workers
yeah I think it's also worth including
the fact that like it is hard for
American audiences correct me if I'm
wrong at any point it is hard for
American audiences to understand the
full Peron Cult of Personality whether
it is Peron himself or his wife or his
third wife uh I believe Isabel so after
he was even exiled and living in Spain
for a while I mean basically his wife
Isabelle who had been the vice president
was sort of installed as the president
and then when he died she sort of
succeeded him and so to some degree you
have these three people with the last
name Peron who are just exercising vast
influence and power over all of
Argentina for I mean three decades
longer yeah it's it's kind of stunning
that like think sometimes American
audiences don't fully grasp the intense
Cult of Personality no no no I mean the
the cult of personality that Pon
implemented was extremely uh deep like
you still have people today you know
people in their 80s 90s remembering how
they were forced to learn about Pon and
aita in school and you know they
remember being forced to read books that
said you know uh Pon loves you Evita
loves you uh Evita um is is is what
what's best for the people because you
know she U she gives us food she gives
us bicycles she gives us whatever like
the cult of personality was really
really important and as you mentioned
you know pedon made both uh both his
wives um his running mates you know in
the 50s and the 70s this is why when he
died you know uh Isabel Peron was then
put in charge of course she had no power
the only reason why she was there was
because she was pedone's wife uh but
yeah it's true he actually ran a
campaign that was you know vote for pon
pon because you know he was Pon and his
wife was Pon so the color personality
the authoritarianism was very high he
incarcerated political opponents back
then back in the 50s um he uh seized um
media Outlets you know the the largest
newsp the biggest newspaper in Argentina
La pra was shut down and was forced to
like you know go from at a time it was
forced to to just print you know like
two or three pages a day because the
government wouldn't give it paper you
know to print on kind of like Venezuela
in the in the early 2000s well we
experienced that back in the 1950s in
Argentina with theone he was a very
authoritarian figure I think sag say
something so yeah well when so when mle
is railing against the political cast
he's he's you know he's positioned
himself self as an Insurgent candidate
an anti-establishment
candidate this is really who he's
railing against uh is this what grew out
of the Peron movement uh he you he even
talks about just this like revolving
door of family members and connected
cronies is that more or less what he's
talking about is that
movement in a sense it is I mean to to
just to continue you know with the
timeline you then get to the 2000s and
that's where Nestor kishner claims to be
you know Pon successor and and he does
the same thing that Pon did in the 1950s
he names he actually well he he does it
just slightly different but in a sense
it's the same thing he leaves the
presidency but names his wife as his
successor basically of course now you
know um ker did not incarcerate
opponents he did not seize uh media
Outlets he still sort of engaged in you
know passive aggressive intimidation
campaigns against the his opponents but
it wasn't like a big deal you know and
the people were the ones who voted for
his wife but in a sense it was kind of
like the same thing that pedon had done
um some decades ago so you have kersner
then you have Christina kersner um
particularly after Nestor kishner died
in 2010 he she became the leader and
from that point from 2010 she became the
undisputable leader of peronism and
here's the thing you know it's a it's
very tricky for other pists to try to
counter um her you know to oppose her
because she retains the support of
something like 20 or 25% of the
population and so that's not enough to
win an election which is why she has not
uh stood for for election for example
this time but it is key uh in terms of
the primaries you know if you don't get
uh Christina kushner's supp support you
don't get a paranis candidate so Masa
you know um to to round out the the
explanation about Masa he h ran against
you know Christina kersner in 2013 he
lost but then in
2019 um after president makri um had
governed but was deemed failure you know
so so it was clear that he was going to
lose reelection Masa rejoined Christina
Kushner and they both installed current
president Alberto Fernandez um in the
presidency so Masa sort of waited his
time and he waited and waited until
Christina kersner became sort of weak
enough so that she could not um oppose
him as he wanted to run for president
then what happened was you know a year
ago the minister of economy resigned
there was uh one of many runs against
the peso you know inflation was
skyrocketing too um and Masa took charge
Masa was offered the ministry of economy
he accepted and from that point on he
became clear that he was going to be the
candidate of the parist or or the
workers party so he's now representing
the left well let me ask this because
you know if he's been the minister of
economy this entire time that
Argentina's economy is essentially
melted down how is he even how how does
anyone even perceive him as a credible
candidate given what's
unfolded you know this is going to sound
uh paradoxical but his lack of
credibility is actually a plus for him
at this point because there are some
people no no I I'm being totally serious
because many people like like my dad my
dad thinks this my dad thinks and many
people think that Masa will get rid of
uh kerser you know within the peronist
party and then he will take a right turn
as he becomes president and will do the
things that he's supposed to do you know
he will open up the economy gradually he
will you know actually Implement fiscal
adjustment but with the key support of
the workers party which if it were to be
opposed to him it would cause him you
know a very serious headache so there
are many people believing that Masa is a
sort of fult candidate you know that
he's not the true Workers Party
candidate that that people who like
Christina Kushner are being forced to
vot vote for him because there's no
alternative because their
administrations had been so bad that
Christina kishner cannot run uh for an
election again um but that Masa is
actually going to you know um stab them
in the back like like he did in the past
and he will create you know his own
movement within peronism that will just
you know get rid of kation once and for
all so
think they think he's like a wolf in
sheep's clothing to use an expression in
English like somebody who's going to
come in like he doesn't authentically
believe um these things I mean even his
his role wasn't he serving in um
Christina kirner's government in 2008
2009 like do they think that he's just
been lying or playing at cool this
entire time is that like an
authentically held
belief yeah uh and and to give you a bit
more of context uh that is credible
because it has sort of happened in the
past you know back in the 1990s yeah
back in the 1990s we had a president a
peronist president called Carlos menm
and during the 90s Argentina experienced
uh one of the most impressive
liberalization moments you know of it
history but minim uh actually won uh his
presidential campaign back in
1989 promising you know populist
policies you know that he would be the
defender uh of
protectionism um that he would increase
handouts that he would increase public
spending and then he started he started
out his government um he he was actually
running amid a hyperinflation and after
he took office he produced a second
hyperinflation but after that he sort of
turned completely and he became the
champion of free market in Argentina you
know and he
deregulated um significantly Argentina's
economy he privatized many uh
state-owned companies he lowered um
public spending significantly for a
while at least um and he got rid of
inflation you know inflation was a
chronic problem back then and he decided
to Peg the peso to the dollar and in
that way he basically eliminated
inflation and so this happened in the
'90s so many people now and and now you
know moving to melee this is why many
people you know think that um well it's
complicated but I'll try to make it easy
many people fear and other people desire
uh that this happens again you know that
either Masa becomes the new benom
uh which I'm not sure if that can happen
or um that if mle wins then he will do
the same thing that manam did you know
that he will get rid of inflation by
taking this drastic measure of dollariz
in the economy
um yeah there's a certain craziness to
the fact that people almost semic
conspiratorially believe that Masa will
do that if elected even though he's not
saying that he's going to do that but
Malay the person who is more explicitly
saying that he is interested in
dollarization they don't believe that
that will actually happen like there's a
little bit of double think that's
happening there
right yeah yeah there is um and so now
going moving to Mia and bullridge for
example um the the main criticism of uh
of M's you know political structure or
candidacy if you will is that he doesn't
have the the people you know he doesn't
have the the the required expertise he
doesn't have the teams uh to govern the
Argentine state which is you know large
and it requires a lot of you know high
ranking officials that the one of the
criticisms of mle is that he has no
people basically that he only jumped
into politics two years ago and that
it's just him you know and maybe 10 or
15 people in the shadows um but that
they can't really govern even if they
say you know they want to deregulate
they W to I mean because they're talking
in more extreme terms than back in the
90s m is saying you know instead of
privatizing state-owned companies we
just need to shut many of them down
because if we privatize them you know
another government will then re you know
um will um seize them you know and get
them back to the state um so we we just
need to get rid of this problem uh once
and for all the same thinking goes for
inflation you know if we try to
Institute you know
um an independent chairman of our
Central Bank of or feder Federal Reserve
uh then you know a potential leftist
government will be able to ruin things
if they pick a dependent president so
let's just get rid of the peso and adopt
a dollar and we will not have this
problem so M's stances are more extreme
than ever before you know for Argentine
standards but the criticism is that he
doesn't have um the expertise to do it
that was the uh advantage of the bullich
campaign you know bull was third now he
she got uh 23rd 23% of the vote and she
represented uh former MRE former
president mre's
Coalition um she was the minister of
security back then which is why the her
expertise was was not the economy she
was criticized for that uh because the
main problem in Argentina right now is
the economy and she did not seem to
understand at you know
sometimes just how bad the debt problem
was for example or the inflation problem
was um but the the the key advantage
that she had was that she had that team
you know she sort of inherited the
structure of former president Maki who
um was in power between 2015 and 2019
and well she she got mockery support um
and Mak said for example when he when
when he justified his support he said
that you know mle has good ideas for the
economy but he will not be able to
actually Implement them he doesn't know
how to do it he's just too new whereas
Patricia bullich you know has been in
politics for a long time she was part of
my Administration she knows how to
implement change so even if her
discourse is not as extreme or as
radical as mle
um she will be able to implement change
people did not buy that she lost but now
you know um I'm not sure if the audience
is aware of this bullrich um went on TV
with mle last night and she announced
her support for him so we'll see what
happens really it was rude of to do that
when we had already prepared for this
live stream you know we had to change it
up and I just really dislike when
politicians inconvenience me like that
yeah
yeah well bullrich you would describe as
a set orri candidate more or less is
that a good way to think about it yeah I
mean I think if we were in Europe uh I
would call her a Social Democrat to be
honest um I I I know bullridge
personally uh I've known her for for a
decade or so I've never seen her talk
about economic Liberty I've never seen
her really care about you know free
markets or privatization or you know uh
right now she was closer to us to
Libertarians because she um well she
advocated for you know at least fiscal
balance because that's the the root of
Argentina's inflation problem um and she
was definitely closer to maybe not a
Libertarian standpoint but a a rational
standpoint on economics uh which which
is why many people wanted to vote for
her um right now she does represent the
center right um but Theos Coalition is
composed of many parties she is the
chairman of the pro party which is mak's
party basically I would call that a
center right party but then there are
other parties who are Center left
actually uh like the UN Civ radical uh
which announced also yesterday that they
will not support either candidate for
the runoff so okay nor Masa nor mle and
then there's a third party which is also
Center left which also uh announced that
they will not be supporting Malay nor
Masa but you know this is significant
because it indicates that that Coalition
may be breaking up after this election
that that's very interesting and I I
pulled up I was looking at some this is
older P polling data from uh May of this
year this was done by The Economist
intelligence and they were comparing
support for Javier Malay by political
affiliation and obviously among
Libertarians he's got strong support
down the other one I've got highlighted
here is uh bull Rich's party and you
know the support is tepid but what I
noticed is that the strongly against is
only 25% so just looking at this as an
outsider that would look combined with
bull Rich's endorsements pretty good for
Malay going into the runoff like there's
a high chance that a lot of that support
would break for him am I right about
that or am I missing something uh and
looking at these numbers and the
situation with the
endorsement um I think you're right uh I
think most votes most uh bullrich votes
will go to mle um I'm just not sure up
to you know which point uh he will
command an overwhelming majority uh
within the hunos pambio Coalition but he
needs that because Masa got 37% of the
vote then you have a if you pull up the
the initial slide you know with the
results I can point to another parist
candidate Juan skti who you see in the
fourth place there he got 7% of the vote
um those votes are likely to go to Masa
just because uh scaretti is also a
parist uh but he has always been um
anti- curer anti- curist um and he would
not join masa for this election um it is
true that his running mate was sort of
flirting publicly with mle um but I
would expect those votes to go to Masa
uh and then the fifth candidate uh was
the far-left
representative um that's only only a 3%
but you know in a runoff when you're
going from 37% up that 3% could be key
so if those votes go to Masa then mle is
going to need an overwhelming majority
of the bu riches uh um of BU riches
voters and that's um I don't think
that's guaranteed I think he will get a
majority of those votes but the
indication that two of the three parties
that compose
hamb that the the announcement that they
will not endorse any candidates I think
that's going to hurt him um it's true
that those are the two um least
important parties in the Coalition uh
the most important is by far Pro because
you know bull uh belongs to Pro Maki
belonged to Pro uh and so their support
is key uh but mle needs all of the
support he needs if he's going to get to
the presidency um and right now uh I
don't think we have any available polls
just because the election was on Sunday
um I think the the the first polls we
likely see something of a tie you know
between Masa and M so this I think this
is going to be very
close did you want to go to some
audience questions
Zach yes there's quite a few that have
come in one is from naram shanuk says
Masa is not Cent left he's a left-wing
populist I from what you were describing
it sounded to me like I I think these
terms get a little confusing across in
different contexts because populist well
you know giving out a bunch of goodies
ahead of the election that's a populist
move here in America we tend to think of
populism as anti-establishment figures
but it's a little muddled here because
he's part of of the establishment but
he's also a populist but and I I don't
know that mle you know he's often
described as a populist I don't know
that he is a populist but he's
anti-establishment there anything else
you want to add to the understanding of
these terms yeah also describe Malaya as
like a fascist or in keeping with
bolsonaro which is sort of not my
understanding of the policies that
Malaya is promoting I think people are
very imprecise with their
labels yeah um so in terms of labeling
um Masa is definitely the uh
establishment candidate I mean he's been
part of he's been in politics for
decades um he's actually calling for a
government of national Unity you know
he's actually courting these parties
these hos poia parties that um will not
endorse mle he he's trying to get them
um you know to be part of a potential
government by him um I would call Masai
populace definitely because of the
measures that he took that he's taking
um and I think at this point he
represents basically all of the left in
Argentina the center left but also the
far left uh and the left just left you
know um because there I mean w with the
farle candidate out for the runoff um
anyone who feels leftist will vote for
him but again I think Masa can uh Masa
has uh switched you know skins in the
past uh he has been rtist he has been
leftist um and many people think he can
actually you know make another um 180 uh
degree turn so we don't really know
what's going to happen U and then you
were talking about mle as sort of a A
bolsonaro or trumpish figure um that's a
very interesting discussion um I
understand why many people have compared
melee to Trump or B
bonaro I am not sure that that
comparison is uh completely accurate
because neither Trump nor bolsonaro
world libert I mean we're self-described
aarco capitalists it's not that M it's
not that M right it's not that mle you
know you know calls himself just a
classical liberal or a Libertarian like
he's he's called himself an anarco
capitalist and of course he has um made
very questionable alliances you know um
he's running mate for example uh she's a
I would call her a conservative
nationalist I think if you ask her about
for example um globalization she would
like to be opposed to globalization or
free trade or fiscal adjustment um and
and I don't think she's you know
libertarian at all um I'm I'm still
struggling to understand why mle would
pick her as her running mate um there
are some theories you know that that he
needed someone um that was not as
histrionic as him uh to accompany him
and she was the only person available uh
that would sort of Court you know um
like um richer voters because I think
really it's that we have a shortage of
libertarian women I mean there's like
what four of us that exist right like he
has sort of slim pickings you know let
meing one more that happens in Argentina
too from Robert weed says are any steps
being taken to prevent fraud before the
next
election how big a concern is that is
that something that's plagued Argentina
in the past um I don't think there are
many steps being taken to prevent fraud
uh before this election um Argentina's
uh electoral system is uh a bit tricky
um and it and it is in need of Reform of
urch and reform just because um for
example the the ballots with which we
vote um we don't have you know just one
ballot where we cross you know the
candidate that we W or something like
that we each party you know uh each
candidate needs to provide the state
basically with their own ballots and
they're sort of responsible for those
ballots to appear um in all the schools
in the country basically so that
requires uh a logistical you know
structure that is very hard to get part
particularly for lesser um known parties
or for new parties and that has always
given uh pism and advantage over others
um Al and also you know the and the
other way in which the system is tricky
is that um there are not always uh
representatives of all parties in all of
the schools of the country and so vote
counting could be um you know altered
and we are seeing actually in very
backward provinces in the in Argentina
like Santiago the EST one of the poorest
provinces of the country um where I
would even call you know their governor
um like a local dictator basically
because it's basically that um in those
kind of provinces we are seeing for
example vote counts where pism gets a
100% of the vote in one school you know
which is just it's statistically
impossible like it it it just can't be
you know um I don't think that can turn
uh the result of the election um but it
is a concern and I don't think there are
being any steps uh being taken you know
to to solve it just because the
government in charge is peronism um so
yeah I wouldn't count on the government
really I want to take us to one more
question and then we'll move on uh this
one's from Joseph on Wagner why is
reason in general so watered down on
libertarian messaging y'all are
basically Beltway Libertarians not in
touch with the movement as a whole I
cannot resist defending uh reason's
honor especially because this is kind of
unrelated to the thing that we're
actually talking about this is a
question for you guys I know right we'll
feel this one one point of clarification
that I would add is you know we're awful
Beltway Libertarians I'm literally
sitting in Queens in New York City and
Zach is sitting in his house in Florida
so if we are Beltway Libertarians we're
extremely bad at it because neither Zach
nor I spend any time in the Beltway um I
have to zoom in for the cocktail Pary
so uh no but I mean I think that this is
such like a weird strain of critique and
we get these types of messages all the
time um I mean I don't really understand
what the specific complaint is here I
think taking the Malay candidacy
seriously is not watered down
libertarianism honestly I like the vast
majority of things I hear coming out out
of his mouth he sometimes phrases things
in a little bit more of a blunt brusk
trumpy type way but you know what it's
not very off-putting to me I I really
appreciate how much of a straight
shooter he is and I'm sorry but we're
fundamentally a journalistic outlet I
think it's important to be engaging with
International candidates and trying to
take this comparative lens seriously and
then actually talking to political
experts on the ground like Marcos Falone
in order to understand what exactly is
going on and what these Dynamics look
like so I mean if you don't really like
reent Style uh and you think we're too
Beltway Centric that's on you but
there's a lot of issues with that strain
of critique uh and I don't really
understand what you want us to be doing
instead or how we ought to be engaging
with mala's candidacy differently I for
one am very interested in it and I'm
sorry but like this is what journalism
is and absolutely in no way dismissing
Malay as some Trump or bolsonaro copycat
I think we're taking him seriously and
actually trying to do something
different than what a lot of the media
is doing in their coverage of him
where they sort of paint him as a
far-right candidate or a populist or a
fascist or a Libertarian as if
libertarian is a dirty word uh I mean we
are Libertarians we don't believe it's a
dirty word and we see him as pretty
distinct from those other candidates
yeah and he recently we I want to get to
some of those uh exciting melee Clips
because I agree with you Liz there's a
lot to like there it's it's hard not to
watch it as a Libertarian and you know
get get the old uh blood pumping we've
got a few clips from his recent
appearance on talker Carlson show on
x.com in September following his first
place finish for Audio Only listeners
these are going to be dubbed in English
but first uh I want to ask you a
question about this in a moment uh where
he explains his animosity towards
socialism let's run that
clip
are you arguing that socialists commit
Bloodshed because they believe they are
God
om
it's it's you know it's exciting to hear
a political candidate pulling from hyek
books and essays and packaging it in
this really
fiery attit ude uh but how much do you
think that this really these really
visceral ideological attacks on
socialism explain his appeal in
Argentina is that something that
actually resonates with the average
voter so I think that uh resonates with
his base uh and I think you know that
there's a very um there's a very
interesting feature in that clip which
is the sort of Christian language you
know that he uses when he talks about
Heretics and and capital sins you know
and and I think um I'm not sure about
this but I think this is part of a
strategy um in which mle is trying to um
sort of appeal to uh religious people
because they know because he knows that
if they believe in him they will follow
him you know no matter what uh no matter
what and and that's you know I think he
considers that uh important for his
political campaign but I understand how
that could make a lot of people think
that he's not a true libertarian that
you know that he's actually uh a
trumpian candidate or a bonaro version
uh of Argentina um but I think you know
going back to to the question of his you
know ideology and what does that have to
do with his success um I would say that
meay
um owes his success mostly to
Argentina's failed economic policies
really because we are in a country that
has not grown in something like 15 years
you know we've been going from recession
to recession inflation has been um you
know increasing year to year and people
feel like um they have tried it all you
know that they have tried peronism that
they have tried anti- peronism back when
Mii was in power and that nothing has
worked and so people for example young
people um a boy who's like 20 years old
he was born in
2003 um everything he's seen you know
everything this person remembers of
Argentina's political life or and
economic life is failure you know and so
what they're thinking is what does my
future look like in this country it
doesn't look good you know and so this
person what they want is they want to
leave Argentina and we're actually
seeing that you know I have many many
friends who have gone abroad and many
who and many don't think that they will
return to Argentina um and where do they
go you see you know well they go so in
Argentina it's typical that many people
have um some sort of European
citizenship you know uh because of our
heritage many people have an Italian
passport or a Spanish passport and so
they go to Europe um some of them go to
us we don't talk about that just kidding
that's true that's
um but you know an overwhelming majority
is either Italian or Spanish there are
some Germans too but there not as many
some imagine how bad of an economic
situation it must be to be like I'm
gonna leave Argentina and go to Italy or
Spain right like not exactly countries
known for their industriousness and
productivity and participation in the
right not ideal but apparently better
yeah so and so I think you know M feeds
on that basically you know on the lack
of Hope of the people and that's why he
sort of presents himself as a savior
basically and this can be you know this
can be uh interpreted in religious terms
too you know he I mean he he's never
going to present himself as God of
course and he's criticizing people who
think that they're God but he's sort of
you know trying to present himself to
people and particularly you know uh
lower class people people who have lost
all hope that he will rest restore you
know Argentina and and you can see when
I talk about this I think I I even think
about how this can be related to Trump
you know when he was talking about you
know make America great again um I think
well you guys know more about Trump than
I do uh I don't think America was never
great really but in this case it is true
that Argentina has lost something you
know Argentina used to be one of the
richest countries in the world and now
it's just average basically you know we
don't do that attempt to lay this at the
feet of socialism and socialists is that
something that excites people or that
res that they resonate with um is that
something that kind of haunts the
political landscape whatever effect
socialism has had on Argentina because I
know we talked about peronism and it's
it's a little different it's just kind
of hybrid but how does that factor into
the political landscape
right so I think his um you know his
campaign against socialism uh everything
he says against socialism um is is
something that of course he believes uh
and that his base also believes
particularly uh the young people you
know students uh people under 25 or
under 30 I don't think that's something
that resonates among um Lower Class
People for them I think the message
that m is getting to them is that
whatever is happening to them is the
fault of uh the political establishment
um which he calls Casta uh right cast
maybe the word in English I'm not sure
um but he talks about the political cast
you know he he says he tells people that
everything is uh the fault of the
political cast and that he is coming to
drain the swamp you know like Trump did
back then in the US
um his message against socialism in
particular I think that excites uh a few
people not not the majority of his
voters but a key you know a key group
that is for example the group that uh
takes the lead on social media the group
that sort of sets the agenda on social
media and so when you go on Argentine
social media you will see that
influencers for example uh that like
Melee and talk against socialism are
hugely popular which is strange you know
because that's not that's not a thing
outside of social media really um and it
makes it look like it's you know this
generalized thing you know this
generalized opposition to socialism
which I don't think
exists that yeah that that might be what
I've been exposed to is just these
social media influencers the memes the
chainsaws which I want to talk about
because he is fan there he is on the
cover of in an AP article wielding a
chainsaw his supporters there's videos
of them running chainsaws I even saw a
guy with a chainsaw mask like walking
into the voting booth uh the title of
this article for our listeners is a man
a plan a
chainsaw and that's because mle uh has
presented something called the chainsaw
plan uh here this quote at the beginning
to your point he says the cast is
trembling um he yells while brandishing
a chainsaw uh and he presented the
chainsaw plan in central Cordova
Province uh in June 2022 it is his
blueprint for the wholesale reform of
the state to slash public spending scrap
half the government's Ministries sell
state-owned companies and eliminate the
central bank that all sounds pretty good
to a
Libertarian if he is elected what are
the political realities how much of that
of his agenda do you believe that he
could
accomplish well that's a that's a good
question uh because it's it's key to
what many voters are considering uh when
thinking about voting for mle um the
reality is that if he gets elected
president um his party will not have
more than
15% uh of Congress seats neither in the
House of Representatives nor in the
Senate so he will command a minority uh
and not even the first one uh the first
minority will be the paranis party then
you will have the hoso Coalition if it
still exists and otherwise you will have
many small parties and then you get his
uh so he will not have more than 15% of
all Congress people which is going to be
a problem for sure if he doesn't cut any
alliances you know now the question is
after Bull's endorsement uh last night
um and we're expecting a an endorsement
by a formal endorsement by President
mukre who's just he has informally
endorsed him but not officially yet um
if he cuts an alliance with them um he
may increase the size of his you know
legislative uh group uh but it's going
to be hard for him to form majorities in
Congress and then there's the question
of who um who would be you know part of
his team of his economic team uh who
would be uh his um ministers his
minister of economy for example uh we
don't really know much about that
there's some expectation that um an
alliance with bullich and MRE will
provide him with the kind of people you
know he needs people with the expertise
people who know what the challenges uh
inside the state are um but it's it's
unclear really uh what would happen also
because after you know he won the August
primaries and there was this Panic you
know uh in markets he sort of um backed
down in a way from his
proposals because before that he was
just saying he was talking about
dollarization but there were no
specifics in the program and it just
seemed like he would dollarize the
economy on day one you know but after
the August primary and to try to calm
everyone down he said you know
dollarization uh is something that will
happen um in the not in the long term
but not immediately either you know like
in 12 months or 24 months and there will
be a transition period and things will
be smooth you know so as to not hurt
people so in a way it's unclear exactly
what he will do and with whom he will do
um all of the all of his proposals which
is what's scaring people now you know
many people um on the center right are
thinking well the election is over um
even if I vote for mle he's probably
going to lose but if he wins he will not
be able to do anything so many people I
I I what I sense these days is a lot of
um of sadness you know on the Senate
righteous because M didn't do better on
the Sunday election and because um the
math doesn't really add up neither for
the runoff nor for potential
Administration but you know Argentina is
like a Pandora box Everything Changes uh
significantly like you know week to week
so everything could change how how much
autonomy or you know how much
cooperation would he need in order to
push that the what's really the central
proposition of his campaign the
dollarization the abolition of the
central bank is that something he would
have much Lee with way in doing even if
he had a uncooperative
legislature um and is there a way we
talked about a little bit the beginning
but is there a way to implement
dollarization do you think that would
not create the sort of nightmare
scenario that spooked the
markets well um the alternative you know
to to hyperinflation if you want to
dollarize is to borrow money basically
and now that's where you know M's
capacity to attract
Investments um get sort of called into
question um if mle for example were to
um seal you know an alliance a a a an
executive alliance with bullich or mocky
then those people may be able to uh
convince you know investors to borrow to
lend the Argentine State money so that
the state actually has some dollars you
know to dollarize and so that the
exchange rate doesn't need to go to the
through the roof uh that's that's the
alternative um it will require that the
state uh take a lot of debt um it's
unclear whether mle would be able to do
that and if he were to do that then he
would have to um proceed with his uh
fiscal adjustment plan uh much more
quickly than expected because he would
have to pay that debt down of course um
and the state is already in deped so
that would be a problem um and uh what
was the first question I I I forgot
about that sorry uh it was just could he
how much buyin does he need from oh
right and and he needs yeah
and I'm not sure about uh technicalities
um yeah I think that um he may have
people on his legal team trying to
figure out whether he could bypass
Congress for many of the proposals uh
that he wants to implement I'm not sure
he can do that um Argentine presidents
do get a lot of leeway through decrees
but there are some areas in which um it
is constitutionally forbidden uh to
issue decrees I don't think I'm not sure
if monetary policy fits into one of
those categories I don't think so um but
it's likely that if mle does something
that Congress doesn't like uh Congress
does have the authority to override a
decree you know uh if Congress gets
two-thirds of a majority then they can
override whatever it is that the
government is trying to do um and so if
that's the case and mle can't get
one-third of Congress to to support him
then he would be in danger um he would
be in my view the the most important
danger that he would face as president
is um that he would get impeached uh
impeachment would be would be a real
possibility because if he only has 15%
of the vote you know he's just you know
uh whatever he does that the opposition
doesn't like they will turn that into uh
grounds for impeachment and they will
impeach him for sure um if he's
unpopular enough of course if if that if
the opposition thinks that it will be in
their benefit to impeach mle they will
do it uh that's of course assuming he
will actually get elected president but
I think that's the that he he's his
biggest concern right now should be that
really because the the election for
Congress has been done already that's
not going to change with the runoff and
he will just not have uh many congress
people so that's what I would be
focusing on right now how to avoid
impeachment on day one or day two yeah
that that's you know the the political
climate and uncertainty presents a lot
of uh issues for for mle that um I think
is making some
Libertarians nervous there's been you
know there's a lot of excitement among
Libertarians about mle because like when
else do you see a guy like this who's
the head of a presidential race you know
spitting Hayek and Mis
um you know uh on the brink of winning
the presidency but there's been a little
bit of push back in some quarters some
of it because of uh some social
conservatism which we can talk about but
some of it because of a fear of how he
might react
to his political opposition um there's
another clip from the Tucker Carlson
interview that this brings to mind where
he is asked what happens if there is a
backlash and there are riots once he
implements these radical plans let's
play
that there's this
enormous State Workforce government
Workforce in Argentina but you said that
you would not lay them off immediately
until you built up the private sector
economy because you worried there would
be violent
protests are you worried that there will
be violent protests or violence against
your supporters over the next month
before the
election
a little smirk at the end from Dr
Carlson what one of the fears that
Gloria Alvarez expressed on our last
stream talking about Malay is that she's
worried he could end up acting like
another pachet and start getting violent
and authoritarian and tarnish
libertarianism in Latin America how
concerned are you by that
Prospect I'm not that concerned uh to be
honest um I do think mle has some uh
psychological you know uh issu isues you
know he I I do I do peculiarities how
dare you say that about our favorite
tantric sex coach come on what I mean
and how dare I say that among
Libertarians who are very sane always
right very nor yeah very normal very
normal um I think you know I I do I I do
ask myself sometimes how mle uh will
would face opposition and what he would
actually do you know as a person what he
how would he try to react to opposition
um but I think uh institution uh
institutions in Argentina are very
strong um and he I don't think he would
pose a threat to democracy at all or to
our Republican system um just because of
the of the weakness that he would have
from day one you know I was talking
about how he's not gonna have more than
15% of Congress people so he could be
impeached any second we know that um
people on the Supreme Court you know
justices don't like him so they could
also strike whatever it is that he does
down um so and I don't and you know of
course people within the state you know
people who work for Argentina's
government um some of them are you know
people who have who have led
professional careers uh over decades but
many of them are also people who have
been appointed by the ponist
administrations who will try to you know
boycott Malay from day one so I really
don't think that he will post a threat
to our system um I do worry you know
that about him you know as a person
about how he's going to feel if he can
do what he wants to do but I don't think
that's a problem for the system
necessarily that's a really good point
like the greater threat might be just
that he ends up being kind of inept at
implementing the things that he wants to
but not necessarily that he you know in
any way encroach is on sort of rule of
law the way that people are claiming I
want to bring us to yet another clip
from uh the Tucker Carlson interview
alas uh despite you know possible
disdain for Tucker Carlson which I I
sometimes feel it was a really
interesting and thorough interview with
Malay I think Malay was especially
fascinating in it because Tucker kind of
continuously pushes him to almost be
more of a trump-like figure and Malay
kind of jur on that and says no I'm I'm
a Libertarian I'm a capitalist and sort
of repeatedly brings up Hayek uh and
stuff like that which is clearly sort of
not what Tucker is wanting um but this
clip was about abortion and I think this
is an interesting thing to explore
because many Libertarians are very
divided on this issue and I know this is
pretty big in Argentine politics sack
can you bring that one
up
Def
to me this so succinctly sums up how I
look at it uh because I am a pro-life
libertarian and I understand many
Libertarians um begin to feel very
concerned when when you get into
questions of well if you do believe
these things then what role does the
state have in restricting somebody's
ability to get an abortion and are there
any second order impacts that could stem
from making something illegal when it is
so prevalent uh in you know both the US
and in Argentina um and you know we want
to learn from the harms of Prohibition
in other Realms and so a lot of
Libertarians even if they may maybe feel
a little personally pro-life have
trepidation about the state getting
involved in this um Marcos how do you
think this plays with vois in Argentina
uh is this something that turns off a
bunch of Libertarians or would be
supporters is this something that turns
off young people or is this actually
playing pretty
well um I think this was actually part
of U his strategy to appeal to Rel
religious voters uh particularly because
um we there was a first attempt uh in
2018 to pass uh a a federal law that
would um allow for abortion to to be you
know legal um and free for all um that
was rejected by Congress back then uh
mle was not as important of course as he
is now but he he opposed it um and I
think he tried to Rally you know
religious voters behind him uh in doing
so um that is besides you know he's
actual beliefs he he does believe he he
is a pro-life libertarian too uh and
then uh I think it was 2020 or it might
have been 2021 when the abortion law was
finally passed um abortion is nowal in
Argentina abortion for the first like 14
weeks
right yes that's correct um and and and
women can get that in any public
hospital for for free of charge
basically or you know with the with the
tax or Spain basically um yeah but um I
think this has been this has been good
for him um to to Rally you know to to
build a base basically which is not
necessarily composed of uh
Libertarians um I mean it's not
necessarily entirely comprised of
Libertarians but does also have you know
conservatives and and and nationalists
um and I think this has been
particularly I mean you know his
position his stance on abortion has been
particularly good uh for him to get uh
many votes uh outside of metropolitan
areas um back in the August primaries
and now also in October um he got many
votes in rural areas uh in in lower sort
of lower income areas um not that he he
he doesn't really get that many votes in
Progressive cities you know um when he
jumped into politics in 2021 he got 177%
of the vote um because he ran for um a
sea in Congress um representing buonas
you know the buonas city um this time
around he also got something like 20% or
less of the vote of the city of
buenosaires but he keeps getting you
know something like 40 up to 50% uh in
many provinces that are just you know
far from wiid is who are more
conservative and where abortion is still
um a very contentious issue because in
the city of buid is in the metropolitan
areas you know people just moved on
really uh and accepted the fact that
abortion is now legal and nobody's
really trying to do anything to to uh
you know uh repeal that law uh but in
these provinces you know in in these
provinces for m is getting more support
uh abortion is still an issue and it
will be an issue forever most likely
because you if you're a pro-life uh
person you know an anti-abortion person
then you think that the basically a
genocide is happening in front of you
all the time so this will always be an
issue and that's where he got more votes
uh so I think you know strategically
politically for him um this was good you
know even if you know he can't appeal to
all Libertarians because there are of
course some pro-abortion Libertarians um
we we know here in Argentina that
libertarianism uh is uh Sharp you know
split in this topic which is probably
the most contentious one really uh in
philosophical terms yeah I'm a very
pro-life libertarian um but I did want
to ask Zach I know that you and I um
diverge a little bit on this question
and policy implications
aside what do you make of like is is
malle's argument at all compelling to
you or does it really turn you off of
his ideas I mean look he's making the
strongest philosophical case that you
can for being pro-life as a Libertarian
I still have a disagreements on what you
know basically my disagreement boils
down to at what point is it appropriate
for the state to start prioritizing the
protection of the fetus over the
mother's bodily autonomy that's really
that's the nub of the issue for for
everyone and I think we're on opposite
sides of of where we would say it's
appropriate for the state to intervene
the bigger concern for me that and one
that's been expressed is what you
alluded to earlier Marcos about the
having this so in having the libertarian
ideas so entangled with the Catholicism
and the religion I mean part of it might
be you know those of us who came to
libertarianism in the early 2000s or the
90s it's like we remember the days of
the religious right uh you know trying
to craft policy here in the United
States so we're very on edge about
libertarianism being overly associated
with social
conservatism I think with Malay you know
I I've looked into his policy his
statements on social issues and he's
always seems very careful to say you
know I'm not uh a
I I like I'm not against gay marriage I
just think government should get out out
of marriage alog together or um you know
I'm not you can become whatever you want
to become I think he says you can become
a cougar for all I care just don't make
me pay for it so he's taking a strictly
libertarian stance on all these hot
button social issues but uh what Gloria
brought up in our last conversation was
well at the same time he's not advancing
any policies that are libertarian on any
of the social issues he's kind of just
saying the philosophically correct thing
but he's not doing anything to expand
the liberty of people in these
marginalized groups and that therefore
all of these people who it's important
to are NE never going to get on board
with libertarianism if their idea of it
is Javier mle I don't know I I don't
know enough about what's going on in the
culture in Argentina to aine on that one
way or another but maybe you
do um no I I I agree with you that um he
he's very careful to to take the the
mainstream libertarian uh you know
approach to all these questions uh and
that there have been people criticizing
him for for not being a Libertarian
enough um the criticism that I respect
of course um but I also think that you
know libertarianism can house you know
conservative Libertarians people who
believe in libertarian principles but
would not necessarily adhere you know uh
and do not necessarily like um the
things that people do with their
Liberties you know I think m is very
careful to to respect you know as he
calls it uh the the life projects of
others um a definition that they took
from that he took from an Argent
um academic um and and yeah I think
that's not a problem to me really um
because I agree with those mainstream
libertarian statements but I understand
why that is a problem for others who
would want mate to be you know you know
better on that I I agree with you by the
way that social conservatives absolutely
should be part of the libertarian
movement so long as they are pluralists
like the rest of us and don't want to
impose their preferences on us by force
um and it's the Malay model is just very
interesting to look at from an American
perspective because I we are having a
lot of these same tensions and
discussions in the libertarian movement
in the United States and I think there's
a lot to learn from watching the Malay
Campaign which is why we're hosting the
conversation I would also add the site
caveat that
that I mean obviously you're you're
talking about a few things wrapped under
the umbrella of being a social
conservative but I would say that at
least for me my pro-life views and I
think many pro-life Libertarians feel
this way aren't I'm not conservative I'm
not a social conservative I am just a
staunch libertarian who disagrees about
when life begins and if life begins at
conception then all kinds of policy
implications follow and I see this such
as such a natural um area where if if
the non-aggression principle applies in
all other Realms then if you see a fetus
as an innocent and rights bearing
individual then surely that also applies
in that context too I still want to
celebrate your right to do mushrooms you
know I'm I'm not a social conservative
and so I think there might be a
contingent particularly of younger
Libertarians who perhaps feel that way
uh in both the US and in Argentina I do
want to really evolve it's a it's a
rapidly evolving issue especially with
just the scientific and medical advances
is I think there's an increas seems like
there's an increasing number of people
in your Camp Liz who you can't just
divide cleanly into the you know
religious rights and uh you know left
camps that way based on their view of
abortion I'm not interested in
controlling women's bodies or telling
them what they can and cannot do or
telling them not to have a good time
right like that's
not yeah yeah exactly right like you can
look at my body I'm interested in giving
people lots of bodily autonomy um I do
want to bring us to one last question
and then close us out here uh this one
I'm not sure who it's by but it says the
Tucker Carlson interview should have
been uh a at reason TV really
disappointed a Libertarian presidential
candidate wasn't approached by reason
first oh well um Zach do you know who
that one came from um I'm not seeing
that there um oh it's by phelip by this
guy Philipe um I think that's such a
great point I totally agree I am bummed
that this was done by Tucker Carlson and
not by uh me or Zach or uh you know one
of our reason TV colleagues our
executive producer uh Jim Epstein our
head of Reason TV who actually is
totally fluent in Spanish uh if the hob
team wants to approach us uh in any way
I think we've tried to approach them if
they want to do something with recent TV
I mean we are hopefully we have
demonstrated in this stream and the last
one we are not interested in just
lumping him together with bolaro and
Trump we have a lot of I think tough
questions I think a lot of fair
questions that we have you know that
have been rattling around in all of our
minds um so win or lose talk after the
election Malay team yeah we would
absolutely be interested there are a
bunch of interesting angles to go down
and frankly it's a really heartening
kind of exciting thing to see somebody
who's so proud of the anarcho capitalist
label somebody who's so proud of the
libertarian label somebody who names
their freaking dogs after free Market
economists uh you know really taking to
the National stage uh and the
international stage and I think he's
talking a lot of sense we're definitely
interested in continuing to follow
what's going on in Argentina
economically because this crazy like
runaway inflation I mean we talk about
inflation in the US but then you turn
your focus to Argentina for a few
seconds and you realize I mean this is a
massive issue and for anybody who cares
about riging and government spending and
ensuring some sort of fiscal Prudence
going forward we really really want to
make sure that some of the mistakes um
in Argentina aren't emulated in the US
and we also kind of care deeply about
what happens I mean the fact that so
many younger argentines feel like they
have to seek other opportunities abroad
instead of being able to contribute to
Argentina's economy because of how dire
the situation is that's a huge problem
and I think it's important for
Libertarians to really pay a lot of
attention to this um so Marcos spone
thank you so much for speaking with
reason where can people find your
work um they can go to Marcos falcon.com
and they can find everything that I do
basically there you know links to
podcasts uh media articles interviews my
Twitter account uh an email address so
all there wonderful well thank you guys
so much for tuning in to reason TV Zack
Weiss Miller and I will be back uh next
week probably the exact same time with a
new stream for you guys we really
appreciate the time